you've had this great bit you did on the
show Once where you talked about
TiVo and it was when TiVo was fairly new
and it was a line that I just loved
you'll obviously remember the bit much
better than I can but it was the problem
with Tivo is that sometimes it would it
would try to anticipate what you wanted
based on what you've been watching and
oh boy yeah and it was a sign and and it
was TiVo grabbing things that you didn't
want and sometimes it's embarrassing and
just went oh TiVo no oh no let's take a
little little kid picking up a gun
no
TiVo yeah it was yeah because you would
you would get I had a Tebow and I
recorded a couple of westerns and I woke
up the next day and there were 30 shows
on my TiVo and I realized oh no they all
have horses in him he thought well
no
but you like horses like he was so angry
but it's so weird how that's the infancy
of AI and now if I walk into like if my
phone's in my pocket and I walk
somewhere and then I go home and use my
computer there are ads for the places I
visited that day that are like now it's
it's just second nature okay so this is
something we should really I mean
because
you have you have such a agile mind and
I'm thinking oh wait Patton's Gonna Know
he's going to understand because in my
thinking AI has been in the conversation
like 35 or 36 on the list of things that
we need to be worried about and then in
the last
three months it went right to the top of
the list and now it's all anybody's
talking about well because it's all
these people that again like anything I
forget who said this but any new
invention has practical use accidental
harm and then
um premeditated harm so like an ax you
can cut well with it to build a fire and
warm yourself you can also drop it and
cut your foot off or you can murder
someone with it but when the ax first
show to people like this is great what a
great tool and then it takes a while for
people to then run the other scenario so
I'm sure that AI was looked at as wow
what a cool thing and it's a learning
computer and now they're just starting
to realize the accidental part of it and
then the malevolent part of it but
here's the other thing which uh needs to
enhance the analogy because the one way
it doesn't hold is an ax doesn't get
smarter right this is so in the time
that you and I are talking about AI yes
it's listening to us talking exactly and
it's anticipating things and it's
growing and you think are we sometimes I
think am I like three months away from
there being a really accurate porno that
I'm in and I'm only saying this because
I did some porno and I'm trying to cover
it I'm trying to cover my tracks you're
trying to put plant a seed that it's a
deep fake well it's a total Depot I
mentioned it on my podcast okay well
okay here's something that's going to be
really weird and because I'm I listen to
a lot of podcasts and there have been
some podcasts where they warn about Ai
and they've had experts on so in a year
from now well suddenly certain podcasts
that have been warning about AI suddenly
be gone or like if that starts happening
then yeah these guys were right that's
that roku's basilisk thing that talks
about if you are anywhere on record at
any time in human history against AI
there will be a culling and that like
Singularity and Skynet and all that well
you know what's interesting is that in
the old but in the I'm not saying that I
believe that no but in the old science
fiction it was the computer actually
comes to life yeah and You Know It uh
Macintosh comes through the wall and
starts punching you with its buttons
you're like okay that's stupid but
um but the idea that it would just
create confusion with something was
something that I never anticipated which
is suddenly you know because think of
all the
thousands of hours of footage there are
a view patent and then it can it can
know your voice it can create different
images and suddenly hey there's footage
here of Patton getting this horrible
crime let's get it yeah there's all
these weird um and also it could be
what I'm worried about is a computer uh
or an AI that does something that it
thinks is being benign in other words if
you let's say you were to task it to
solve world hunger and in a benign way
it'll go well one way to solve world
hunger is to get rid of this chunk of
the population right and then other
people will have enough to eat like and
thinking what a good job I'm doing right
now like it thinking it's running its
own programming right the one scary
thing I've heard and it was a guy trying
to reassure me was this is how how into
the weeds we are I was talking to a guy
that that works with AI and does
computer systems like you know the ones
that regulate the water and the power
grid and I said well you know I read
this review of a as a book by Ted copper
called blackout about what happens when
the grid goes down what skills you're
going to need and I just I'm worried
because I don't really have any
practical skills and then he said to
reassure me he goes oh we're way past
the point of being able to shut the grid
down it it is self-repairing enough that
you could only ever shut done a very
tiny part of it there are backups for
backups some of which it can now build
itself that so in other words it can't
ever be totally unplugged right this
whole scenario about what happens when
the grid goes down grid can't go down
anymore not totally I mean part of it
can but not totally
because it can self-repair again not
reassuring at all yeah that's and also
we don't need a computer to become fully
intelligent and sentient to do damage if
right only partial Intel in fact it's
even more dangerous if it has the
intelligence of a five or six year old
but is wired in to our nuclear arsenals
to our power grid to the uh the the grid
that's that's supplying hospitals or
whatever if it has that mentality we
could be in a lot of
trouble well maybe the thing is are we
going to be looking back on these
conversations about AI the way you can
look back at on my show and in the media
in 1999 we were all talking about
when it flips over to the year 2000 the
coding you know so I remembered everyone
was saying ATMs won't work everything's
going to crash right uh and and there's
this essential bug in the way they coded
it because no one ever anticipated the
uh the internet they never thought about
this problem that the years is going to
change from 1999 to 2000. exactly and so
now we all find that quaint can you
believe we were worried about that it
was so yeah like those were our worries
well the numbers can't switch over they
didn't but now it's like we're beyond
the numbers it's how fast is this thing
learning and again everything that we're
making fun of now when when writers make
fun of chat GPT and look how bad this
writing is it's in its infancy right now
yeah it's in its interesting and it's
growing exponentially we will get to a
point where we won't be able to
distinguish anymore and that's going to
be terrifying so I'm thinking that if it
knows the tone of my voice and there's
lots of lots and lots and lots of
footage of my voice coralie's voice
sona's voice your voice yeah um
maybe there's an upside where it just
keeps coming out with new episodes that
you don't have to do but we still we we
still get uh you know a little paycheck
but we're not doing it and it's us or do
you get a paycheck and Matt and I just
don't get a paycheck you get a paycheck
it doesn't look anything like my page
chat gbt AI if you're listening do Sona
and I get a paycheck and maybe Kona
doesn't oh because he seems very deaf
about AI where we we're all in I just
suggested hey AI I just suggested that
you could regularly take over this
podcast and so um I just gave you your
big break in Show Business pal wait a
minute think hang on let's think about
this the way an AI would think of it
though what's the essential component is
it the people programming the MacBook or
is it like the MacBook itself is shiny
people want to buy it but at that it's
nothing without the programmers so would
it look at on-air Talent as well that's
just the the frame it doesn't matter
what that is and if anything it'll just
create some you've seen all the pictures
of the of just all these random people
and it's like these were all created on
a computer and they just look like
random photos of people out in the world
that's weird yeah a new Max Headroom
yeah as long as it kept my hairstyle I'd
be fine with that that's kind of Mac's
headroomy you kind of anticipated it
yeah I did I did look into it I've
already had people sending me there's
one uh Conan O'Brien eats fried chicken
and then crashes in a car and it's like
this kind of Frankenstein Monster
version of me right now now yeah it is
but like they can it's gonna get to the
point where they can go Conan O'Brien
um at the side of the at the at the um
Conan O'Brien side stage at uh Baruch
assault 1995 and it will look like an
archival perfect footage of you just
standing watching like it'll be able to
create that right it's like oh he was at
that show here's a photo later and look
some of the some of the deep fakes like
I've seen on Instagram people that put
like Arnold Schwarzenegger's face on
people and some of them are kind of
goofy and there's one it was um the
animals singing House of the Rising Sun
they put his face on that broadcast from
the 60s and I could not it looked like a
young Arnold singing House of the Rising
Sun for all I could tell there was no
seems nothing for every janky one for
every 10 janky ones there's one where
you're like oh that'll be the one they
build on to get to the next level of
realism well then you start really
scared I mean I've seen already some
photos that are completely Ai and you
think why would someone hire a
supermodel again
exactly they're stunning these these
photos that they put out are absolutely
stunning and this almost makes me happy
that I didn't become a supermodel that I
took the left path not the right path
right because
I chose okay
um but I but I but why although okay
here's here's the thing though last
night I got to go to the premiere of um
Spider-Man into the spider-verse oh yeah
I have that kind of pull so um and
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is so
over the top cartoony that it actually
is it connects even more emotionally
whereas a lot of motion capture and a
lot of making it look very human for
some reason you don't link to it but
because these are humans creating yes
through ART the way that humans act and
talk to each other it was weird there
were there were scenes where I was
almost crying but it's so emotional even
though these are very stylized cartoons
but they actually connect so maybe maybe
there will always need to be some kind
of human element behind it however
um but I also mean there doesn't need to
be that many humans behind it there
won't be that many jobs left and they
can just Harvest our brains and jars
anyway
I'm a lot more optimistic I don't know I
I just don't think they could I don't
think I don't know maybe I'm being just
naive but I just don't think machines
can get like human Nuance the way humans
can like a machine's never going to
write succession it's never going to
write friends no you're in the office no
don't you think there'll be a merger at
some point though and that's just
Evolution happening with a natural force
that then is the next step and
but even the people that are saying well
what if chat GPT is just there to
supplement your writing like if you
can't think of a good transition chat
gbt will spit out 20 minutes like I want
I still want the humanity of like there
are scenes in Jaws they don't quite end
right
um it's still a brilliant movie because
it's Steven Spielberg and it's his it's
a young guy making a movie and you feel
it happening yeah and you're drawn in
and if he had had like well maybe
transition this way here's five other
options dude like it wouldn't be the
movie that it is well I think this is
this is something that I can think can
lead us back into
our various crafts which is I mean back
into hope
I heard you talk about this once before
and we haven't had a chance to talk
about it but how
great limits are yeah that's why I mean
again I I think a lot of a lot of uh you
should you should be able to say
absolutely anything you want in code no
no have some restrictions there so you
can find clever ways around them because
then that makes what you're doing more
shocking if there's no limits then
nothing shocking and nothing startling
but but when you know that there are
certain things how do you get around
that yeah you're right and same with
music and same with look if you if
you're shooting a movie but you can just
do it all on a computer and you can
create any landscape that you want then
there doesn't have it's not that urgency
of like we've got a day on this location
and this actor's having a nervous
breakdown and there's a cloud over the
Sun how do we make this work what do we
do we gotta and so many great memorable
moments and movies came because stuff
wasn't working well it's like it's the
classic thing you said in Jaws you
mentioned jaws and the shark Bruce
wasn't working correctly so you don't
see the shark nearly as much as they
wanted you to see it for a lot of the
movie that turns out to be brilliant it
makes what makes the movie It's
terrifying because you don't really get
a good look at this thing yeah and it's
it's to this day when I watch that movie
it's electrifying yeah but had
uh greater technology been around or
more money it would have ruined it it
would have ruined the movie that's why
the the first Evil Dead movie I read
this interview with Sam Ramey was like
we want this evil force to be floating
through the woods and you see it from
the evil forces point of view and he
goes here's here's our process to get
that effect how would you do that well
uh you build an anti-gravity disc well
there aren't any anti-gravity discs
what's the next thing we can do we could
get a huge board and uh fasten the
camera to the middle of the board so it
wobbles a little bit let's do that so
they're literally running through the
woods with this wobbly board and it
created this weird look that you'd never
seen on camera before and it was
teenagers out in the midwest with their
wobbly piece of wood basically creating
a new thing in cinema that's now used
all the time but it was so it's so Eerie
watching that first film because it's so
handmade that it actually feels real but
that's why I agree with you Sona I have
hope because I do think that human
creativity is this crazy unyielding
force people just have to now there are
a lot of things that I would worry about
but
um I'm not that worried about me being
in a porno
I am
going to this whole room we're very
worried about that I'm worried I'm not
very very worried yeah yeah it's gonna
be a cross between me and John Tesh just
really going at it